it's the flying dutchman read another
report that out of service
my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and hello everybody and welcome to
another episode of 13 o'clock episode 37
as it happens yeah so we're not marinum
we're back to never again yeah I guess
so well cuz I know when this one's going
up so we're not like you know and what's
a topic on us on today we're going we're
talking about how scary the ocean is I'm
already monsters and go ships yeah
everybody knows that the ocean is bad
you know you don't need to be on you
don't need to go there wait for people
no all you got to do watch a series I
shouldn't be alive yeah whatever this
man we're just like no whoa that's not a
place for people to be it's oh no don't
buy a boat full hostile environment a
boat is a hole in the water you throw
your money into it could eventually kill
you and it will before we do that
without some housekeeping to do yeah the
Gennie's new book unseen hand the audio
version of that is selling like crazy
and most of it is our listeners and we
really want to thank you guys yes thank
you very much awesome yeah so far I
think it has a five review yeah I felt
that people are putting up reviews I
really appreciate that
right and we're something she said she's
averaging like two or three sales a day
which is good for an audiobook that I
haven't really done much promo on yet
except on right I've done a couple
others a couple little shows I was on
every day that I was on Jim Harold I've
done yeah a couple other one yeah now
another thing is that we've noticed that
the way Jenni's books are being
displayed on audible or kind of crazy
because math Mountain poltergeist is not
under Jenny Ashford it's under Jennifer
Ashford which I can't figure out how
that happened or not I'm trying to sort
that out right like it's not a huge deal
it's still on there but it's like it
doesn't come up like under my author
name right so and I'm not audible it
does audible it does on Amazon yeah it's
all my own yeah it comes up on Amazon
that's fine but if you're looking for it
on audible yeah you know that's the way
they have it so we're gonna fix that
yeah we're happy we're trying to fix
that and
No and then also there are the
Audiocodes
oh that's right yeah I wanted to save my
new books at unseen hand I still have
some free audiobook codes not a lot but
if you want one then you can contact me
and contact me on youtube you can
contact me on Facebook or whatever
through my page and I will send you a
code if you write a review it does have
to be long it could just be a few
sentences saying how awesome it is yeah
you know just kidding just like fair
review you know yeah but you know and
another thing is just that we have some
leftovers from the older books too I do
yeah now here's what give those away
yeah like yeah so I'm not entirely sure
they still work because I don't know if
the codes have some kind of limits on
like time limit on my list but I do have
like for all my other books house afire
whispers Rochdale poltergeist mammoth
mountain poltergeist I have some free
audio book codes for those jail yeah
left over normally I get about the
industry people but they're not asking
for when you work with it that books not
for well so that's yeah other fans yeah
cuz I just you know the relays yeah so
like I said you know it would be really
really cool if you write a review of it
if yeah because that's why I'm giving
them out yeah it helps it helps spark
sales and in the books yeah everybody
like pretty much everybody likes them
anyway yeah sure yeah the only other
thing we had to mention oh we were going
to mention the spooky Empire that's
right now spooky Empire they just had
the spring one in April and they have
one in fall in October I think it's the
first weekend of October I have to check
just in Orlando and it's here in Orlando
it's usually at the Orange County
Convention Center and if you want to
meet us in person yeah or buy some of my
books in person alright you can get
wound round autographs and everything we
will be there yeah and we're actually
we're going to probably be on a bunch of
the author panels and stuff like that we
did it last year they actually put us in
charge of the best author Pam chicken
twisted mannequin towards the infamous
and we will have booths can we give out
free booze yes alright so free booze if
even if you don't give a [ __ ] about us
I'm good come on and the last one was
pretty fun with we got asked to do the
last one on short notice so we didn't
have a lot of
promotional materials we do have a big
yeah I had like a William I had like a
weeks notice like a weeks notice and
we'll have a lot of books to sell and I
don't think we'll bring t-shirts but
we'll bring like try photograph flyers
of the t-shirts yeah you can see what
they look like yeah buying an inventory
of t-shirts could cost a lot of money
actually because we don't get them that
cheap yeah they're really just the shirt
month the shirt company gets all the
money yes I mean the books are not that
much for me to buy but you know yeah
depending on which book it is no but
yeah that's not cuz Santa - Santa
Petersen was there Larry yeah who else
was the kids from stranger things were
there they had a panel Tom Savini was a
he's at every Tom Savini is at every
single or convention ever
yeah Lucky's been at every single one I
her walk advice I see a table Cellini he
looked to get my math book I may have
met one a long time ago like for a few
minutes he looked about half drunk
here's well yeah I don't want with a
word he goes to those all the time yeah
but he seems like an okay dude yeah and
because I was like a big fan so I was
like all excited to meet him yeah
there's ago so if you guys are in local
in the area if you want to come down to
Florida and go to Orlando but a spooky
Empire you guys will love it it's a
really good Convention Center it's huge
yeah the only thing I've bad about I
have to say is that we had a hard time
getting an internet connection in there
yeah I don't really hard time with the
they hadnít Wi-Fi I think you had to pay
like to get one password
yeah which means that we couldn't I've
had a hard time using my PayPal peer
account you know two reps to charge
money for you know to the voter for the
book and and the button on the food was
outrageous and bad yeah that's another
thing like don't tell anybody I said
this you guys but bring a lunch they
haven't they have like a food court in
there but it's a little overpriced and
very referring on to that it was just
that what was what was it like a little
pizza hat like a micro Pizza Hut yeah
and it had like a change what was it a
Mexican Korean restaurant and I was very
terrible that was weird that is maybe
that maybe that it would be different
vendors there I don't I would imagine
because I think they're modular and they
show up and yeah they're just logically
just show up whenever
yeah in terms of like the food
yeah but I'd recommend it if you get you
know that I'd bring her food and yeah go
down your well but I can get a public
sub been bringing it a cooler talk about
four days huh well sweet notes three
days every nurse it starts like late
Friday night and then it goes through
Saturday and then it goes through Sunday
afternoon yeah so if you guys want hang
out with us we'll be there yeah we will
know as the date approaches will will
will hype it more yeah pretty sure its
first weekend of October apps check or
not never but anyway okay so let's get
to the topic now like I said we're
talking about the ocean we're talking
about lyrics that's kind of romantic all
the kind of romantic and spooky you know
legends about the ocean usually sea
monsters and go ships and stuff like
that yeah which is always kind of
fascinated me because even though and
this I'm not ashamed to say I am
terrified of the ocean I would not go
out in a boat you couldn't pay me to go
out in the middle of the ocean on a boat
no way how do you on a cruise ship [ __ ]
that I've been I've been out of a
fishing yeah like out in the open ocean
yeah give up Gulf of Mexico
Nana kind Pacific Coast million come
from California but now yeah you get
seasick yeah smaller boats even with
like even if you don't get seasick here
today the ocean you know comprises two
thirds of the globe right and we have no
it's miles and miles deep in places we
have no idea what the hell is down there
so you know ideas I want to start with C
Mon that's why we're starting with FEMA
okay
now okay the thing about CLC monsters
are one of the most commonly reported
well quote-unquote legendary creatures
they go back to the to the Greek age
well yeah Greek Golden Age any monsters
cracking yeah and is it well see here I
was going to say to you I mean the
Kraken is the most um you know most well
known and everybody associated with
Greek mythology but it's actually not
Greek no the Kraken the name the Kraken
is like Scandinavian so there's
scandinavian sea monster you know okay
now the whole story because i think that
happened to The Clash of the Titans
honestly what happened was in Clash of
the Titans even the original one they
made with Harry Hamlin it whatever the
one day make that 1980 or nice animal I
don't know I love that I saw them I
loved that movie too but the thing is
there is a
in Greek mythology where Perseus kept
Andromeda from getting eaten by the
Kraken but it wasn't called the Kraken
it's called the fetus the c2c et us
which is a great word that's why they
call whales and stuff like cetaceans
those over comes from the same legend
there are all Greek causes and stuff
they show that scene and it looks like
an octopus yeah now and the weird thing
is built like the original Clash of the
Titans that they made like with Harry
Hamlin it like I said for some reason
the Kraken and that one looks like
Godzilla right look this looks cool yeah
am i common and then well he kind of has
like fins on his face sorta yeah it's
kind of a creature from Black Lagoon now
when they remade it um with what's the
name that played quite quite onion I
can't order dammit but on the remake the
Kraken was much bigger and it looked
more like like a Cthulhu type of thing
it had one eye gold and [ __ ] like that
okay
the strange thing about it though is
that early like the earliest legends
about the Kraken or about Sita's sir
about stuff like that not I'm some of
them not so much like an octopus most of
them more like a whale or a crab
leviathan kind of yeah although that was
later I mean that was a bit more
biblical story but the thing is though
that I think the idea because it's in
the Bible to the Leviathan a giant sea
monsters yeah a giant sea dragon really
yeah but see I think that comes from
Sumerian right well do you not that's
right TMI dr. Perry if we had dr. price
on he would tell you right now that the
Kraken a violin the dragon and all of
that is Tiamat and that has to do with
Marduk destroying a cosmic space dragon
and then ripping his body apart and from
that he made the universe yeah and and
that da 20 that's what the Tiamat was
yeah okay now then she started out as a
goddess but later that was one of her
form the other day Kirstie Dragon doors
are retold in the Old Testament and the
New Testament and every time is retold
it has a different cultural spin on it
yeah because it's being told of you by
their storyteller
that's now dr. price believes that in
the New Testament in the Book of
Revelations the scene where the dragon
is thrown into the abyss
actually is kind of a metaphor of qiyama
taking the earth or the creation and
throwing creation into the void and
because remember in that part of
Revelations God is getting rid of the
physical universe and everyone will be
live in heaven yeah so destroying TM on
and throwing the dragon into it into
hell is kind of a metaphor you know for
reversing creation yeah cool the
interesting thing too I hope that was
intelligible yeah yeah I'm sure you're
gonna like what no I was just looking at
because you were talking nothing oh good
okay I wanna fitting how you makes me
feel like I'm doing something wrong
no I I was looking out chickens listen
enough yeah I think that's kind of a
cool idea
the only thing was based on TMI and the
destruction of team well and also you
have to in Norse mythology there's also
the Midgard serpent right which is like
a huge sea dragon that got so big that
it encircled the entire wolf encircled
Midgard right yeah yeah and then it got
so big that that it could eat its own
tail like an Ouroboros right I think you
know I think all these I think all these
motifs or I had a common origin and an
instigator that's what I'm wondering
about their own legends well the thing
is though that I mean legends of sea
monsters pretty much every culture that
has anything to any kind of seafaring
history has sea monster stories yeah and
you know some of the most popular
there's there's Korean Won there's
Japanese ones there's Filipino one
there's all kind of stuff now they all
have pretty similar yeah it's I mean
it's hard to tell just between a sea
monster and a dragon the further you go
back into the in into time energy story
yeah
TMI and the Midgard serpent may be
different tellings of the same it might
be the same thing right now there are
also like I said now the Kraken
originally started I was like a whale
like creature or a giant crab leg kind
of creature kind of later evolved into
like of you know that octopus rawr type
of thing there's also something called
and please I know I'm going to pronounce
this wrong but let me see if I can do it
the ASP addo Cologne which is usually
portrayed and this is very common to an
animal that is so large that it is
mistaken for it
yeah this thing's our trip now the
Astrid Oh Cologne which has some other
names too it's usually portrayed it
originally started out in the literature
it usually portrayed is a whale almost
more modern kind of drawings and stuff
like that usually portrayed as a giant
sea turtle right like a sea turtle
that's so big it looks like an eye that
looks like an eye like it's got like
trees and [ __ ] on Zak and what usually
ends up happening it's usually a
malevolent creature like it looks like
an island to lure people to their deaths
like people land on thing it's an island
and then in some stories like the the
crew will like light a fire to cook
something and then the you know the
animals like hey what's that on my back
and then you get a mini suck some down
dry water and that there's like there's
a huge amount of [ __ ] stuff for that
we all got to imagine who you are you
know you're an ancient seaman yeah and
you're sitting there you're looking at
the oceans horizon all day long maybe
you might see an island you know the
mind might play tricks on you man wonder
if that wouldn't that be a trip that's
just a back of a creature when that you
know that's a scary concept so maybe
then that tail just gets handed down
like a meme you know I mean yes some of
those things are moving yeah and maybe
that might jetan that you might be able
to justify bad navigational practices
and and incorrect maps
hey there should be something here and
it's not it moved yeah they must have
been alive yeah I swear to god it wasn't
because I'm really just bad at
cartography yeah well you have to
imagine the earliest maps and I was
going to say there's a map public Carter
marina that would I think he came out
1544 and they said now around this time
period when maps were not super accurate
and they weren't really worried about it
too much they would often draw like
these heraldic animals or sea monsters
on it but they're not really sure if
people thought those were real animals
or if they just put them on there as
kind of decoration you don't think we
had a guy who was making a map and he'd
probably the ravenna see you're seen in
you this stuff you just seen other
drawings yeah so he's gonna take his own
spin on it now one of the ones I always
like listen you know like octopi big
giant I was a big squid you know Terence
yep support yeah which you know that
concept is kind of plausible think about
see this is what I was thinking because
like we were saying about the you know
the the one with the island I was like
look if you were out on a ship and you
had never really been on a ship before
and you saw the back of a blue whale
yeah those things are enormous yeah it's
like I could see thinking that was maybe
an island or a bit least a big huge rock
coming out of the water because there
you or you see that you go how big can
these things actually get right
especially if you just saw part of it
and you're like imagining that oh it has
like a bunch more like underneath the
water that you're now seeing I saw a
video ragazza looking over the edge of a
boat and there was a giant squid yeah
which is they're very rare
yeah but the giant squids couple feet
underneath the water and it's getting a
piece of meat off of the hook yeah
because they had some bait in there and
that thing was huge I mean his body
seemed to be a size of a bear with long
tentacles yeah if you were in the 1500 s
or the you know and you're out of seeing
the fifty-ninth and you see that that
would freak you out you would [ __ ]
yourself those that might be able to get
into the boat yeah that's a demon that a
damn monster and you know things like
that have killed people yeah I'm going
to get rid in recent times you know guys
will be out in a small fishing boat it's
got low sides on it they've got a light
they're fishing at night they're
tracking the fish and then just out of
nowhere boom
tentacle comes out of the darkness and
pulls a guy into the water never to be
seen again you might think man that's
crazy that doesn't happen no that does
happen yeah it's called the Humboldt
squid yeah and the Humboldt can get to
be the size of leopard and they are
ravenous Lee hungry they're intelligent
and they can see above the water [ __ ]
what's that Oh handy not that big and
boom pulls you into the water yeah and
then bigger than you do about there's
nothing you can do about it that thing's
the size of the leopard and in the water
he's there jet-powered and there are so
much stronger than you they'll pull you
to the deep into the deep and they can
take a bite out of you the size of an
orange you tell me that can't kill you
oh hell yes that could kill you oh yeah
and they need each other
look yeah they go into frenzies and eat
each other but some of them like attack
whales and [ __ ] like that do you know
they're not I mean right and the thing
is I was watching because we were
watching a bunch of CMOS sea monster
stuff yesterday
and there's news footage of a crew in
newsy New Zealand boat crew and they
caught a colossal squid yeah we check it
at a giant squid yeah which is bigger
than a giant squid
yeah and they actually you know it was
like hours long struggle to like get it
because they wanted to take it back for
science even though it wasn't you know
what there that wasn't what their
mission was but they caught one anyway
and it was the first one that had been
caught alive because they had seen them
washed up on beaches and things like
that but this thing was big I mean not
it wasn't like it wasn't like you know
those old drawing to me was like the
octopus it's like bigger than the [ __ ] I
got in the ship right yeah but it was
still big enough to scare the crap out
of you well that come out of the water
imagine if you've heard these stories
about guys being killed by tentacles
yeah all right there talk about the
Humboldt squid and then another time you
know a year later you look over the side
of the boat you see something like a
giant squid down there trying to get a
piece of meat all right yeah all these
stories are gonna be passed around in a
local local tavern yeah you're gonna go
damn man that stuff down there that can
kill you it's big and if you see a giant
squid or a colossal squid you would be
after things fishy here in these old
wooden ships wouldn't vote if that got
into the ship it would kill people yeah
well they were pretty intelligent you
know and this is before a commercial
fishing may the Rosa's is a bigger whale
population you know bigger ocean
populations for all we know and there's
no you know fishing so think think these
creatures probably could have lived
longer and gotten bigger there may have
been squid and occupy big enough to
maybe pull a board off of a [ __ ] boat
oh yeah and stick a tentacle in there
and grab somebody try to pull it out
they're smart enough knowing foods into
when food is yeah its present oh yeah
cephalopods are not dumb they're not
dumb if you got got to have throw and
Chum
over the side every now and then are
fish pieces and those those occupy gotta
go like hey man there's food in those
nice yeah you know even it was before
yeah I should know when they can in
there student it wouldn't surprise me
maybe they'd crawl the side they got
tentacles yeah and across the side get
inside the ship grab something and then
just jump back over well what happens if
they grab a guy yeah or if a guy just
see
there you have to grab the guy the
Sailor just sees it and in his mind his
superstitious and as fearful as they
were it was coming after me yeah that's
what you can say well I think that's
what happened I'm not one of those
people that has to think and one I don't
think it's super crazy that an octopus
as big as a ship might once have existed
or could still exist look in the deep
ocean
well they're as big as ships yeah and on
squids are pretty damn been a lot of the
ships of the day when those drawings
were made were pretty small yeah we're
not huge so like I said if a whale can
get is about as big as a boat I don't
see why octopus run I would think all of
the takers would be to see an octopus
octopus with a body that was about the
size of the small bear or a bear not
counting tentacles and that would be
enough to send dudes in to draw those
pictures yeah of something about the
size like I said the more that it got
passed more about it might have gotten a
guy down bigger right oh yeah do I think
there's an octopus the size of an island
probably no I don't know but is there
one that's prop that's almost as long as
a small boat sure I can say that well I
think that would be one of those giant
octopus if we use giant squid I think if
you even added the tentacles to I think
it was like what 50 20 20 feet long 20
yes something like that well I think the
colossal squid that that crew from New
Zealand caught I think that was 27 see
ya when you see it in the water from the
surface you're looking down it's kind of
inflated you know yeah and being held
yeah this one had a big ol head they
look huge yeah you get it out of the
water and lays flat it doesn't look that
big yeah when it's in the water they
look pretty damn man now I should say
that um like I said I'm not one of those
people that think oh every single legend
has to have like fact behind it no it
doesn't get thick make [ __ ] up because
people can make stuff up but because sea
monsters are so common in mythology I do
think people are maybe seeing things
that they're exaggerating that could be
construed as sea monsters yeah you know
like I said people were seeing giant
squids they were saying big-ass
octopuses yeah the real thing yeah
big-ass whales that they didn't
recognize like maybe because look at the
scary [ __ ] that's in the ocean that we
do know about we do stuff that's not big
like it's real scary-looking there's
really scary-looking [ __ ] down there and
I'm willing to concede that maybe before
commercial shooting
before you know the ocean had been much
explored Brooke you know some of these
deep-sea creatures were probably really
big and they only get seen every now and
then they'd have kind of like a mythical
allure around them because just every
now and then a sailor would see one and
it would be this big crazy-looking thing
plus you get these big pieces of blubber
washing up offshore yeah and she pieces
a giant I called it lobsters yeah
which people thought were sea monsters
or they thought they were giant octopus
they're actually one washed up in st.
Augustine Florida which is only a few
miles from here and this was years ago
that was and people thought it was a
giant octopus but generally what those
are they call them globsters at first
they think because they're the big huge
things and they wash up on the on the
shore but usually what they are when
they do DNA testing is sperm whale
blubber today is when sperm whales die
in ocean like the blubber like the
attaches use their body and tends to
float in a turn up on the shore
somewhere I even think some of those
genesis genesis some of those stories
like the sirens and mermaids and things
like yeah I think that's dolphins
because we maybe when you think of it
you know like sirens calling you to your
death and mermaids calling you into the
ocean into your death right yeah well
imagine you're at sea you don't really
you know and you look down you see a
bunch of dolphins yeah
begging for food you know you're looking
down at oh yeah dolphins coming back
they're smile
yeah then smiley French oh they're like
oh man look after their smile I know
they're friendly guy next to you goes
don't go down in there they're gonna
call you down in there to your death
they're calling you to your depth that
friendly they're not that friendly
they're not friendly something that
remains art and they meant may have
started legends like that things that
call you that look friendly to call you
to your death some dolphins are very
good company truck and I'm down here one
time in the ground yeah well your love
these guys didn't I swam out sick no
nothing not sure how many sea men and
then some dolphins form rape gangs yeah
are you in we should get often rape
gangs next time on that yeah but um well
it's funny because a lot of times like
people say oh the mermaids thing came
from fantasies or do dogs or whatever
and I'm like I don't know man because
manatees are
are cute and everything well they're
kind of ugly cute they're slow but
they're slow and they're really really
fat and I was like for somebody to
mistake that for a mermaid like a human
woman with a fishtail you'd have to be
really lonely or really hammered if it's
something that is cute and interactive
so I would say probably maybe dolphins
or maybe seals but I think they knew
what seals were you think they would
knew what dolphins are yeah have any
seals are very curious they're getting
about with you and they'll try to
socialize night yeah seen some YouTube
videos yeah it'll just feel like jumpin
up the air go hey you got any whales
done hey how are you guys doing what I
was going about that but yeah so what I
thought I was going to say something
else about the Kraken oh you know what I
was going to say this about the Kraken
too this is kind of interesting because
if any of you guys are kind of science
nerds like I am Carla carolus linnaeus
the guy that invented a taxonomic you
know thing we've started where he
started classifying animal now his first
publication system military that came
out the 1700s had a Kraken as a real
animal okay in it now later editions he
actually took the Kraken out now he did
he took it out of his little system but
he did mention it many but although he
said you know it's supposed to live like
a but by Norway but I've never seen one
right but so it's kind of interesting
how I mean because you know there
weren't that many people out on the
ocean really right they didn't know a
lot about what was going on down there
and you know so there's kind of a lot of
back-and-forth about well were these
real animals were they you know throwing
people thought they were he was a lot of
them they were going by other people's
word you know oh I saw this thing with a
long neck that looked like a
brontosaurus yet here I'm here to tell
me that a whale could have a horn on it
I wouldn't believe you but then they
were seeing the narwhal oh yeah that
really doesn't mean it's like this oh so
that's why you can't really I don't
think you can discount all of the
stories like I said I don't I don't see
there being like an island sized octopus
or anything or an island sized turtle
yeah but I can't like some of the weird
[ __ ] that they said they saw like oh I
saw big a squid yeah they caught one
like yeah but everybody thought it was
dumb if their own life
ah yeah tripping no way to know later on
they're like oh they were right there I
think maybe back in the 1500s 1400s and
all that was going on
those creatures may have been more
plentiful little bit bigger and bigger
probably more aggressive yeah might have
been because you know they weren't using
internal combustion to navigate they
were just using sailboats I imagine
cleanliness wasn't too good in the
shadow they had it priced smelled like
food just like a little food float yeah
well yeah and they're gonna try to get
into that boat get some to eat yeah yeah
you think there's no engine sound to
scare him away
yeah true you know you know Edward how
smart could an 80 say it seemed 80 year
old octopus be he weighs a couple
thousand pounds or something like that
imagine that he's bigger than a bear is
maybe 80 years old imagine with it with
an octopus brain you can get pretty
smart yeah and you might be like that
old Oxford and and I don't really know
if there's I mean ocean animals tend to
get larger if there's enough food
decision because there's no really limit
- yeah it's like alligators there's no
limit to how big an alligator can get
yeah you know there's enough food around
for them to eat nothing else kills them
and they just keep growing and growing
and everything else true they're even on
how long an alligator can live no I
don't think they know they don't know
and I've seen no I I don't know like an
alligator that they've had they've had
alligators are over a hundred years old
and they're just as healthy and just as
energetic yeah they seem to not later
age in the same way I mean I don't know
maybe crocodiles are the same yeah I
don't know I don't know what the biggest
alligator I've ever seen probably about
19 feet yeah we root in Florida we
actually see these things I've you know
guys I was driving from Orlando to
DeLand one time and um I saw an
alligator running across the highway
running yeah and I was like I had to
[ __ ] I have a job like I was like oh my
god I've seen aliens just hauling ass
across
yeah and they almost got hit by a car
the local mirs news tears awesome not
only here a lot of Florida man stories
on the news with Jillson here every guys
every time every time these guys got
golf and in these big golf course
there's always a giant alligator found
in the golf course net not out there
golfing and like a
twenty-four foot long alligator just
hanging people haunted that picture that
went around the internet went viral they
thought that was fake that I was right
that was a real life later I'm back in
the day back in the day that would have
been considered a dragon well yeah you
know
alligators scare the crap out of me you
guys they really do and if you actually
if you're ever in Florida and since I
mentioned st. Augustine earlier there's
I think it's still there the alligator
farm now they used to have as a
crocodile and I think he was from New
Guinea but his name was go back and he
was like the biggest crocodile ever
found and I thought when it was alive he
died later and they stuffed him and like
so he just said there's a display of him
stuff he was a lot more impressive when
he's alive but it still pretty
impressive doing stuff that that dude
not so much how long it was I think he
was like 20 24 feet 28 feet long so like
that but it more impressive was his
curse like how big around his stomach
was right I think you could probably
just crawl into his mouth without him
even feeling it there's like so yeah
terrifying well you know I'm not a
marine biologist or anything but I if
memory serves I think octopuses live to
be very old to some of them yeah I think
they do I think even the small ones can
live a long time
yeah the small ones usually die because
they get eaten
yeah but something that's really big out
in the oh she can survive a long time
because you know doesn't have as many
Fredric predators running after it yeah
so who knows maybe something like these
giant octopus T talking about what was
the other thing that colossal colossal
squid maybe something like that could
live to be 150 years old you know yeah
and on alig is it after it's been 150
yeah if it just keeps growing and if you
don't if you get you don't believe me
watch Jeremy Wade on the river Maas
River Monsters here believe how big a
freshwater lake fish could get a catfish
something that catfish he dredges are
like horrifying really large some of
those medieval wood cuts where it shows
all the bounty of the village - hey we
had this much fruit and this much bread
and this cow and next to it this fish
and the fish and the cow are the same
size that wasn't a lie they were a
lonely fish yeah we're being coddled I
showed you that I've seen grouper that
were about as big as a cow big as a cow
so if they're not crazy
they didn't have my fishing
so it was rare once a fish got to a
certain size they didn't have a block
and tackle to catch it yeah and usually
they got those big ol fish like I drain
in a pot yeah Thank You Jess go go yeah
good track about the water net okay so
we've got to the midpoint right now so
we're going to take a break and when we
come back we are going to start talking
about Coast ships
oh yeah there's some good ones on us
yeah we got some good ones on this one
so we'll be back in just a couple
minutes watch out there's a new terror
taking over kitchens around the world
thrills chills mad cooking skills it
cooks a weekly podcast brimming with
recipes tips food five seasonal specials
and guests galore hosted by horror
author amber balance hey that's me
foodie with over 20 years experience
cooking baking and generally making a
nuisance of herself
you watched Food Network you've read
cookbooks but nothing can prepare you
for it cooks coming to a device near you
some culture courses in clothing is our
favorite store for unusual clothing
shoes and accessories they offer a wide
selection of men's and women's clothing
at great prices so culture also offers
the cool selection of shoes and
accessories steampunk gothic apparel
retro corsets and so much more at
subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that subculture
corsets calm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount subculture corsets calm or
visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 ladies and
gentlemen
Rock Entertainment Network presents whoa
the mentor is the greatest manager of
all time where we once again overcoming
superstar good Great Buddha don't mean
I'm not going to see children ever and
check out oh right up front if you do
while they're at the party Lord Wilson
Paris to yoga are exclusively on project
entertainment network
[Music]
[Music]
you
and we're back talking about the
mysteries of the sea yeah those ships
different kinds of ghost ships some
ghosts some some ghost ships are just
legends of ships ya know I was like the
real Goshen oh yeah there's Hilda there
the thing is when you say ghost ship it
can mean one of two different things it
could mean like a straight-up phantom
ship like a ship that people are saying
that's not really there or it could mean
a ship that is just floating around on
the ocean is bad and pretty
there goes abandoned at sea I always
found that really creepy it seems very
creepy because in history their events
some of these things have been huge such
a skyscraper and then woken around out
of the ocean for sometimes up to 30
years we're gonna buddy on it except
maybe cannibalistic Rex ha ha ha ha
breeding rat
wigs me out well there is nothing very
creepy about the one because it just
demonstrates how how vast the ocean is
something is large wealth as large to us
as a big ship could be floating around
out there and not hit anything 4:30 and
not hit and just for years and years and
not hit anything yeah now and Riggins we
rarely be seen yeah and only be seen
like every now and every now and then
they see oh that's that thing right
there it's just an old Hulk yeah well
yeah there is opening very ears all
those empty rooms and all that furniture
in there kind of like something
exploring with Josh if you ever see that
YouTube channel exploring what yeah
shout out to exploring which I'll do
like we like that YouTube channel yeah
man that's weird when you find these old
abandoned Mandan mansions and abandoned
buildings aren't being Clark like that
it's super creepy yeah I'm not sure like
what it is maybe that's why I kind of
like watching him watching you play
fallout and stuff like that maybe that
why because I really like that whole
creepy croupe it's abandoned people used
to live here there's like all their
stuff and it's yeah you've really been
30 years in 40 years
yeah but the thing is that well okay now
probably the most famous phantom ship
obviously is the Flying Dutchman yeah
now they're not sure if that was
actually based on a real boat or not um
legends of it it actually came from from
sailors folklore like sailor started
reporting that they were seeing this
ship
and initially it was reported as being
like a bad omen like there was going to
be bad weather kind of usually
hurricanes or something like that they
would see this go ship over the horizon
now they also said that if you hailed
the ship then you would get like ghostly
messages like people people on the ship
would ask you to send messages to their
relatives and stuff like that who of
course are long dead right you know but
it was almost always seen as a bad omen
now the actual you know all the real
details about the Flying Dutchman story
didn't really coalesce until later on it
probably got most popularized when
vogner wrote the opera about it he added
that whole thing about the the captain
you know because the whole thing about
it was that the captain was supposed to
be either in league with the devil or
you know kind of defying the gods like
sailing against the wind and the roof of
Good Hope or whatever and so he was kind
of cursed to sail around forever and
never come to a port and you know in the
Opera in Bognor Opera which was actually
based on a book by Heinrich Heine I
think his name is you know that was the
first time where they said that he could
be the captain could be redeemed by the
love of a good woman or a woman that
would die for him or something like that
and he does find one at the end now
people have claimed that they saw the
Flying Dutchman I mean I even up until
the eighteen hundred's 1900s people
claimed that they saw it whether that's
the case or not because here's the thing
there is a very rare optical illusion
that can cause you to see things that
are like over the horizon on a ship like
refracted or MacLeod
right yes usually it's upside down
though I mean usually you see it upside
down up in the sky but not always it
just so it depends on atmospheric
conditions so it's not so much that
these people have been at sea too long
or something like that they might
actually be seeing a ship in the sky
right although like I said you know in
later times I think it's probably less
likely that that's what they're seeing
because it's you know it's an old
looking ship right you would think that
nowadays they would see one that was
more modern looking and then they would
know that it was kind of like a thing
right but so that's kind of you know an
example of like a phantom ship but like
I said other kind of ghost ships are
just ones that were like abandoned yeah
and remember when were abandoned for no
reason or no reason that they know of
Rus and probably the most famous of
those was the Mary Celeste I mean
everybody's kind of heard of that one
right yeah that was that was a ghost
ship but it wasn't a ghost ship for very
long
yeah they reclaimed it in the resold it
knit put it back out to sea but it was
weird they found that ship and there was
and the crew was gone yeah and there
wasn't anything wrong with the ship not
really that they could figure out like
everything was fun like all their stuff
was there and stuff like that um so they
don't know if some kind of cause wasn't
there a bunch of barrels of alcohol and
a bunch of barrels alcohol in it the
crew was gone I think some of the
hatches to the whole world room and the
one lifeboat was missing and it was
trailing a broken rock in a rope so I
don't there wasn't anything paranormal
it was just a disaster at sea I think I
think they thought fire was going to
break out and that some of the and did
they all got in the lifeboat and and
they all got in a lifeboat and it was
towed behind the regular boats that they
were planning to get back on the boat
right and and rough seas caused the Rope
to break and then they all and they
weren't far from from land only about 30
miles yeah yeah wasn't like they were
out and them no they weren't they
weren't lay out in the lower and the the
dinghy broke free and the people were
lost at sea they don't know where the
Big E is the dinghy probably capsized
yeah
and went down and I don't think that
they were out there and that dinghy from
you know weeks and kind of I hope not no
I think they I think it capsized
probably right away yeah all right
that's probably better honestly yeah but
uh you know to go right away and said it
just like languishing out there yes
finally dying of thirst yeah at FEMA I
should be I shouldn't do we keep
bringing that yeah that's you're just
like but like that was what those are
the most fascinating and scariest ones
to me because I think I was going to say
it before but all my worst nightmares
from childhood were about the OSHA or
about being pulled down into the ocean
yet or being swimming in the ocean is
like a humongous monster like passing by
me if you're gonna die at sea you want
to die see right away yeah Mar drown
yeah you don't want to you don't want to
be bobbing out there for a week dying a
dehydration well and also I don't want
like an open water type situation like
that movie where they drew Bob and out
there in the water and then they just
slowly get picked off by sharks yeah
thanks no thank you
that sucks okay now is see we're bad
asses for a reason yeah for real yeah
they're also scum for a reason because
[Music]
you were almost forced out there because
you couldn't live on land the way you
work yeah but some of the I mean some of
the other go ships probably one of the
best-known go ships and this turns up on
like a lot of lists around the internet
of like creepy go ships and stuff like
that is the or Aang McGann or Ora a
Medan I guess I'm not sure is it but and
this is a good story like it happened in
the 40s it's either Ford 1947 or 1948
accounts differ but apparently there was
a ship called the Silver Star and it got
a distress signal I think it happened
the Malacca Strait got a distress signal
from a boat and went to check it out now
they found this boat called the Oran my
dad it was a Dutch boat and evidently
everything was okay on the boat except
all the crew were dead and now were they
frozen or where they all had they were
dead in place frozen effect pointing
fingers and they all had to look at a
pair of her hair even the dog yeah it's
a dog yeah the dog too and that but
nothing else was touched there was no
blood there was no and and a
transmission was sent out that's right
that's that's was the distress call one
and the guy died in the middle of giving
this distressing he said was I died yeah
the rescue ship shows up finds them all
like that and then a fire breaks out
they have to event get back on their own
ship as quickly as possible and move
away from the ship and then it exploded
yeah because they were carrying some
kind of a contraband chemicals so the
story goes so the story goes
but how it all [ __ ] yeah however
total [ __ ] it now there are
online of like the newspaper article
stuff like that but it should be noted
that there is there was no ship ever
registered called the Orion began around
that time or in any country around there
the Silver Star was a real ship yeah but
it's long edge mobs don't show them
rescuing that ship or anything like that
so I kind of think that one is sort of
myth alleged it's a good story though
like with Ulta now there were some other
ones like the Octavius and this is back
in 1775 and the the ship was in
Greenland right around Greenland and
they found the ship ship was fine but
all of the crew members were frozen like
even the captain would have frozen
sitting at his desk Lee was pencil is
hand like he was right missus oh yeah he
was saying like no food 71 days yeah I'm
the last one alive my men that's pretty
spooky I wonder if that really happen oh
yeah I think that probably did happen I
mean good day like could could they just
like flash freeze just like sitting
there at the know you fall asleep okay
I'll sleep then you don't know any
freeze to that yeah and then no you
carry this I guess we'll see that's
pretty plausible because they were up
around Greenland maybe it just got too
cold and they all just kind of first at
us yeah I don't remember the details of
what happened they uh I think that ship
was damaged wasn't it
see I don't know about really cold yeah
and it was a wailing wailing ship and
you know that's like pre they wrote they
were thrilled by the Arctic they found
it like 13 years after it disappeared
like another ship called the herald
found it so that would have been one
everyone thought there was frozen guys
on it for 13 years well isn't is enough
that's enough of the crew dies from
hypothermia okay one day there won't be
enough crewmen the next day to pilot the
ship yeah it would have been what
happened yeah and evidently the the last
guy said that he vide was on there 71
days without food
yeah which my dad's body to eat that's
what I'm thinking I think he probably
and usually ate fish yeah true but you
know the thing is to me it's creepier
like I think another one that turns up
on a lot of ghost ship kind of things is
the joy ISA
that one doesn't seem quite as I mean
it's still creepy that they found this
ship and everyone was gone and they
don't know where they were but that
seems to be less creepy because the joy
when they found it that's a little bit
with what it was a little ship it was
half sunk
you're right which they thought we had
two barrels in it which they thought
that it was it was supposed to be
unsinkable because the hull was lined
with cork and it has all these like
empty barrels of soap so they thought
well there shouldn't have been any
reason for the crew to abandon it but
when they found it with half sunk and I
think they found like bloody bandages
yeah not an accident so I think there
was an accident
or or pirates or something you know it
was probably something like a radio was
also on that when the radio was broken
it only broadcast a couple miles yeah
yeah that was just some kind of accident
at seeing real wave something like that
yeah mechanical failure in the ship it
started to take on a little bit of water
and one thing led to another it's really
easy for one thing to lead to another up
there on the way yeah
and I mean another one can cause six
other problems and then people can die
yeah in rapid succession for different
reasons yeah because the folks turned
over on its side well here's another one
- is that and this was more reason I
think this was 2007 or something like
that wasn't at the caz
- and it was those three guys it was it
was an older guy and two brothers and
they were good what they went out on the
boat yeah yeah they never found them and
they never and here was the weird thing
about that nothing was wrong with the
boat no computers all their stuff were
still yeah their laptops were still on
there was food out like they were like
they were playing on it now to eat
nothing was messed up on the boat it
wasn't wet it doesn't there was no blood
there was no nothing
yeah no reason for them to not be and
the guys were just gone it wasn't
privacy though I think somebody fell
overboard and then another person
without thinking jump down and go get it
maybe although their family said they
wouldn't do that because they were super
experienced sailors like they would have
put out the lifeboat they would have
thought they were working on something
they fell over
they knocked out a lure fishing lure
hung up near work on up here where the
motor was yeah that's right maybe maybe
that guy was trying to get that lure out
yeah
the fishing lure out and he fell maybe
it may be another guy with them maybe
two of them fell off at the same time
you don't know yeah and then the other
guy ran to go I took to the helm to go
get him and he may have slipped off and
then once you're off that boat you
couldn't get back home onto it yeah and
it was running I think was going what 14
15 knots couldn't swim up to good yeah
Joe 15 knots so yeah we fell off he kind
of be yeah it would just leave you
behind
yeah that looks good yes it wasn't a
giant boat no I mean it had to be
something like that because I think
people were like a rogue wave I'm like
yeah but then as the [ __ ] would be
knocked over should be wet you know
stuff and nothing was right so you know
it just looked like they'd all just kind
of you got to look at the probabilities
there's a lot of ships out there oh yeah
all at once all right some of them end
up being these ghost ships yeah rare
yeah but you have enough ships out there
long enough you're always going to have
that small percentage come to rise to
the top in time right yeah and that's
what we're looking at we're looking at
the freak incidences yeah yeah these are
definitely freak incidents in I mean
there's you know it's still it's creepy
to think about that and like I said it's
way creepier when there's when you can't
figure out Roman and like I said it's
kind of like you know when we talked
about the Dyatlov pass incident and
stuff like that it's probably if you
were there at the time you'd like oh
okay like okay that's what happened and
it wasn't that crazy right but because
you don't see that and there's no like
really reason I'm like I said these
three guys just disappeared off this
ship you know obviously it wasn't a
rogue wave it wasn't pirates I mean
there wasn't anything like that
what was the name of the ship that had
the candle restaurant that was called oh
that was called the lee boggs was it
called the lee bog orlova yeah yeah
tildes tell that story well that was
actually okay this one I think was a
ghost ship this is the one I think of
because this is like a huge ocean liner
yes like this is like a huge it's like a
cruise ship the cruise ship pretty much
now it was um it was built in the 70s in
Yugoslavia but they actually
decommissioned it in 2010 and then it
sat around for a few years and then they
were trying to decommission it they were
going to sell it for scrap so what ended
up happening there was like this one
company like was trying to tow it to a
particular place and then they lost it
like it came unattached and then they
said [ __ ] it we're not going to go get
it yeah it was it was like chained to it
she
broke or the lines broke yeah and it was
set adrift and he just said s screw it
yeah I think what ended up happening
there you know because the guy who owned
the boat like owed all this money yeah
they came to take it for scrap like to
recoup the investment and you know the
the crew that was on there like they
hadn't been paid in a while and there
was like [ __ ] this ship you know what I
mean right so they so it got towed
around and stuff like that and then
finally they thought well it's not
really worth it like towing at any
particular place anymore because it's
been so much trouble so they just
basically like let it loose out in the
international waters I kind of float
around and it kind of it came into the
news in 2014 I think it was right
because I think a British newspaper
reported that it was floating around out
there and it was full of rats like it
was full of cannibal rats yeah and this
your breeding camp yeah newspaper said
it was going to come aboard like an
English is just like Dracula coming on
coming on it with me and all the brands
coming out and [ __ ] like that I think
that's probably where they got yeah yeah
now but I don't think that that was the
case how do you press it I'm not sure
I'm pronouncing the Lou you Bob or low
fat or low but it's actually it's it's
bit it's um named after a Russian
builder okay
her name so hurting yes I think everyone
could be an exercise ship it's actually
a pretty sure it is very nice can opener
up float not floating around out there
by itself fall out for style
yeah with that yeah parameter rat well
you're a threat you go you go one of the
berths and you can get your own get your
room spend a night in it by yourself out
there on the ocean right right as a rat
Ichi oh dude and all my second right
balance watching plan cannibal rats
hasn't that shoe God is like this is
middle but not you here run around
inside ship doesn't creepy man a book it
under saying that that I don't want to
tell what happened to the ship what else
is it well eventually it's still out
there far as I know below just float
around they just lay out there since
when since then something like that yeah
now you got new 2013 2013 so yeah now
what was the one that we what was the
one that we had read about the south
thirty-eight years oh yeah which one was
that which one was that that wasn't the
bit that wasn't the HMO was it yes it
was yeah the SS baychimo or HMO or
however you pronounce Adana yeah this
one this one was out floating around for
38 years
yeah and it's a wind ship I think why
not Emily was this doesn't actually it
was abandoned in 1931 okay and it was
also supposedly unsinkable although you
know how it worked out for the Titanic
just saying but so we got kind of cast
adrift and then every now and then
people would see it like around
Newfoundland and stuff like that and I
think it got seen in 1969 like caught in
the pack ice a bunch of into it's not up
there man but yeah so it's kind
now it's probably sunk by now right
there's no one's seen it for a while but
I mean it they say have sightings over
38 years after it was abandoned so it
was just floating around out there
and it was a band for probably uh what
uh it was during a blizzard then as they
as they abandoned it so I guess like the
cruisers were like Professor often left
it I guess I don't know if I don't know
if the you that it was in debt and the
people who owned it were just like [ __ ]
it yeah that's true yeah they're the
stuff is just when we came across was oh
yeah there's like oh my god it's it's
fascinating because there's so many of
these yeah there's so many of these
there's a you know there's one it's a oh
the HMS Eurydice that imagine you're out
there and imagine you're out there in
the ocean right it's nighttime I'm Cree
I'm going you're in one of the little
small pleasure yacht or something yeah
education and you're out there office
you're out there and something huge
moves off you know comes along so I get
you looking into that ship out there for
37 years
that'd be crazy that's create a really
crazy not do is Rusted Hulk not quite as
creepy as if I was looking at the ship
and there was like a giant thing that
came in there was a big guy looking at
me hahaha that's slightly more a bunch
of lies a little rat red
that eyes staring down at you don't want
the boat to get on your boat oh my god
they're that hungry yeah they're anyway
it's been about an hour yeah I was going
to say I was also going to mention the
HMS you aridity if you want to look that
one up that was that was from 1878
another Blizzard got caught off the Isle
of Wight and capsized and then people
started seeing it later on like a like a
phantom ship like right around where a
cap not a cat's eyes because 317 people
died in the wreck so people still
reported seeing too scary and another
thing that's cool about like the phantom
type ship is that a lot of times people
will see them with skeleton crews oh
yeah yeah which can you imagine okay now
I would [ __ ] myself if I saw that if I
was out now I know but it's like I'm not
that I don't have that much of an
imagination so I don't think I would see
that unless it was really there this is
like this scary ship going by that I was
only tricking skeletons on a clock
alright so anyway um I guess we're done
yapping yet because at the end of the
show
oh the free audiobooks where do they
contact it yeah you can either contact
me if you want
um a copy of the unhand and maybe some
of the other my other books the codes
might still work on those too but
actually I would think we actually could
use some more reviews for mammoth
mountain poltergeist so if anybody wants
a free copy of that yeah because I think
we wait till we get that thing
straightened out it'll be straight down
okay I mean I'm sure they'll straighten
it out for you but yeah so if you want a
free code for some of my audiobooks and
you would like to write a review of it
for me that would be awesome
you know just contact me either send a
message on youtube to 13 o'clock or you
know contact me on facebook on the 13
o'clock podcast page or whatever right
and I'll get back to you as soon as I
see your message yeah they range from I
think I think the shortest one is about
an hour and a half the longest one's
long that one is 11 and I've added an
app yeah that the new unseen hand oh
people are liking that one it is like a
one-stop shops over a hundred cases of
poltergeist
poltergeist cases that go back to almost
a 50 Niners when I started with the
reviews of pretty good people like it
yeah people like the other ones are
about individual cases yeah and so I
think oh I forgot to give a shout out to
prod
Entertainment Network that's right we're
number three and yeah for this for this
past month yeah yeah so we our numbers
went up again this past month for April
of our downloads for audio so thank our
podcast yeah well thank everybody for
yeah for listening to the show yeah it
bigger and we're glad you're liking it
and like I said if you have any ideas
for topics you want to do and let me
know I know we've had we've had a couple
suggestions that I have on my list you
need to have another guest again yeah we
haven't had one and said when GP you
have back yeah we should have aggregate
J poke back on because yeah he's a good
guess um dr. price said he wanted to
come back on to maybe do something about
Lovecraft
I did yeah I did I did want to do a
Lovecraft show with him actually because
we had him on before doing biblical
mythology because that's the same thing
but he also is a Lovecraft scholar yeah
so that would actually be kind of cool
if we had them on for that so we'll have
to get in touch with him and you can do
it alright so I hope you have enjoyed
the show and go and like our Facebook
page and follow us on Twitter at 13
o'clock podcast and go to WWE as all
complex Arcana clock and buy our
t-shirts
yeah gets into place on Jane I have to
play a song a song all right by the tail
a very scary tale about two boys who
were searching one day on a very weird
page around dead men one with our
honesty case a safe
I decided dare to traveling in the area
be where we live
[Music]
[Music]